for us to have an exhibit it's it's it's
mind-blowing it really is that's right
this weekend south florida georgia line
kick off their new exhibit in nashville
at the country music hall of fame this
whole place is magic i mean there's it's
oozing full of just country music
history and legacy and
it's unreal i've been trying to circle
my head back all day you know about how
we got here well the florida georgia
line mix it up strong exhibit will take
us through that very journey
complete with instruments awards and
costumes fans can explore everything
from the duo meeting in college to their
award-winning music career you know it's
interesting we've also evolved a ton we
were 20
you know early 20s when this thing
started now we're you know mid-30s and
so as you can imagine our style and our
taste and our perspective and our
everything has changed
drastically so it's pretty wild to look
back and think like a lot of that i
can't even believe i wore in public you
know what i mean but uh
but it's part of who we are and it's you
know part of our story hairstyles like a
knicks but you know whatever